une deuxième syrie voilà ce que veulent
éviter les principales parties prenantes
du dossier libyen
les dirigeants des principaux pays
concernés par le conflit se sont
accordés sur un communiqué final
le but est d'appeler un cessez le feu
permanent libye n'est pas seulement le
secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres s a également rappelé qu'il
s'agit aussi de mettre fin aux
interférences étrangères dans le pays
tous les participants se sont engagés à
s'abstenir de toute ingérence dans le
conflit armé ou les affaires intérieures
de la libye
cela fait partie des conclusions et bien
entendu elles doivent être respectées
ainsi que l'appel à faire taire les
armes à feu avec la fin de toute
hostilité militaire de son côté le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov a regretté l'absence de
discussions directes entre les deux
camps rivaux libyen mais il a tenu à
saluer le pas en avant effectué pour
stabiliser une trêve qui demeure fragile
le cessez le feu est entré en vigueur le
12 janvier à l'initiative de la russie
de la turquie
aujourd'hui on a constaté qu'il était
généralement respecté
bien que des violations aient lieu des
deux côtés
les participants ont appelé le conseil
de sécurité a imposé les sanctions
appropriées à ceux qui violeraient les
dispositions du cessez-le-feu
à l'issue du sommet ils se sont
félicités de la formation d'une
commission militaire composé de dix
officiers 5 pour chacun des deux rivaux
libyens khalifa haftar faya zèle sa rage
elle aura pour mission de définir sur le
terrain les mécanismes de mise en oeuvre
du cessez-le-feu
[Musique]